[Music]
foreign
so I'm pretty excited about this lecture
this is one of my favorites we're going
to draw some super cool pictures uh for
the non-linear dynamics of a particle in
a potential well
the idea here is that if I have some
potential energy surface maybe I'll
actually draw it over here first
so if I have some
potential energy
which I'm going to call V and I'm just
going to pick some potential energy that
looks uh
kind of like that okay so some potential
energy V and this is a function of X so
V is a function of x
that's a function of X then what we're
going to do is we're going to derive the
equations of motion for a little
particle that's rolling around on this
potential energy surface you could think
of a little marble rolling or maybe a
bead that is attached maybe this is a
wire and the bead is kind of moving
around on that wire and so literally
it's height it's it's kind of vertical
position is a measure of its potential
energy and so Newtons which which would
then induce a force given by the
negative gradient of that potential
function so Newton's second law says
that these are the equations of motion X
double dot equals minus derivative of V
with respect to X I'm assuming that my
bead or particle has a unit mass and so
we're going to derive the equations of
motion of how to roll around on this
little potential energy surface good and
specifically I'm actually going to write
down a potential function specifically
for this shape here
and so the example that we're going to
have we're going to have
X double dot equals minus X Plus X cubed
which corresponds to a potential
function uh i e this is for the
potential function V of x equals x
squared over 2 minus x to the fourth
uh sorry minus X
ah
this should be a squared I'll do a cube
in the next lecture I'll do a cubic
Dynamics in the next lecture this should
be uh cubic
okay this should be squared and this
should be cubed over three so for this
potential function which is literally
what I drew here this looks like a cubic
with a minus cubic because it's going
this way plus a positive quadratic this
is a minus cubic plus a positive
quadratic potential and if I take the
negative gradient of this this is the
right hand side force that I feel from
Newton's Second Law so these are the
equations of motion
you can see that this is a non-linear
differential equation if it didn't have
this x squared it would it would be
linear would be a linear harmonic
oscillator but because of this quadratic
term it's non-linear superposition
doesn't hold and as a general rule we
don't have generic
one-size-fits-all tools to solve
non-linear ordinary differential
equations linear differential equations
we actually have you know we can solve
all linear Odes by using eigenvalues and
eigenvectors kind of what I've shown you
so far but generically non-linear Odes
are hard and then you kind of customize
bespoke techniques to solve them but
what I'm going to show you here is that
by finding the fixed points of the
system and linearizing about those fixed
points we can still learn a ton about
the global dynamics of the system so
this is one of my absolute favorite
examples I've been using this for well
over a decade it's one of my favorites
um good
so
um the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to turn this into a system
of first order coupled ordinary
differential equations
so we're going to write that we're going
to introduce a new variable v v is going
to be the velocity of my particle and V
Dot is my acceleration it equals all of
this stuff on the right hand side so
that equals minus X
plus x squared and so I can write this
as a matrix system of equations if I
like
um you know this essentially is a
coupled system of first order equations
and so now what we try to do is we try
to find the fixed points of the system
and then linearize about those fixed
points
and just over here if I think about it
physically intuitively if I really do
have a marble or a particle that's kind
of rolling around or sliding around on
this blue curve then I expect there will
be a fixed point right here because if I
start at the bottom of a hill
um then kind of that Point's going to
stay at rest unless I move it so that's
a fixed point
and probably stable if I push it a
little it'll stay close to that area
this point here is another fixed point
because if I was perfectly balanced on
the top of that Hill I would stay there
but this is probably unstable if I push
it a little bit in either direction it's
going to start rolling off so I'm
guessing these are my two fixed points
that would be intuitively correct
so I have fixed points
so the fixed points
um
first of all they both have to satisfy V
equals zero
because otherwise this can't be equal to
zero so V has to equal zero for x dot to
equal zero so my fixed points x v
definitely has to equal zero and then
also minus X Plus x squared has to equal
zero so um you know minus X Plus x
squared has to equal zero which implies
that clearly x equals zero or x equals
one are the two Exact Solutions of that
equation so those are the fixed points
so we have fixed points I'm going to
write these in Vector form we have fixed
points at x equals 0 V equals zero
and we have another fixed point at x
equals one V equals zero those are the
two fixed points of the system and so
this is x equals zero and this is x
equals one and those are the two fixed
points at x equals zero and x equals one
if I start here with zero velocity those
are my fixed points of my system okay
good
so we have found our fixed points by
literally just setting this right hand
side equal to zero and setting the
velocity equal to zero making sure that
the system of equations is zero at these
two fixed points
so now what we are going to do is we're
going to zoom in and locally linearize
about these fixed points and I'm
actually going to draw what's called a
phase portrait so here I'm going to
actually start to draw that this phase
portrait here
where now I'm going to look at what the
trajectories look like in the X oh man I
should not have used V and V here for my
potential this is really confusing I'm
sorry
this V up here is my potential function
this V here is my velocity I'm going to
retroactively change this to P of X for
potential function maybe you don't hate
me
um I just need to get rid of having the
same overloaded variable this is a
terrible idea
um
let's call this P for potential
let's call this
P for potential and let's call this P my
potential function of X okay in you know
classical mechanics usually the
potential function is designated by a
variable capital V but it's way too
confusing here so my potential function
p p and p Little V here is my
um velocity of X okay that wasn't too
bad so my phase portrait is going to
show me what trajectories of the system
look like in position and velocity
coordinates so maybe sometimes they'll
you know go around in circles or
something like that and again I have
fixed points at x equals 0 V equals zero
this is a fixed point and at x equals
one
V equals zero this is a fixed point so
those are the the two neighborhoods I'm
going to be zooming into and looking
closely at uh by taking the
linearization here
so um the linearization
is based on this Jacobian so essentially
what we're going to do is we're going to
write
um
DDT
my x v vector
equals
um
kind of
F1 of X and V and F2 of X and V
where those functions are you know
pretty simple V and minus X Plus x
squared
and now essentially our linearization is
going to be based on the Jacobian the
derivative of this uh this function with
respect to X and V so that's going to
give me that the Jacobian DF
d
uh we're going to call this you know
this whole Vector X under bar that
Vector of x's DX bar
this is a matrix of partial derivatives
partial of the first equation with
respect to X
which is zero because this is V partial
of the first equation with respect to V
which is one partially the first the
second equation with respect to X which
is minus one plus two x and partial of
the second equation with respect to V
which is zero okay so that's the
Jacobian matrix and we evaluate this
Jacobian matrix at each of these fixed
points to figure out what the linearized
Dynamics would look like in each of
those fixed points
so let's uh let's do that so the first
fixed points uh first
fixed point at zero zero
we find that our Jacobian dfdx
evaluated at that fixed point zero zero
so I literally plug in x equals 0 V
equals zero everywhere I see it in here
that Matrix is
0 1 minus one zero
and this is one of the canonical
examples of a linear Center we actually
already analyzed the system this thing
has eigenvalues plus or minus I and it
is a linear Center so this thing has
eigenvalues
um let's say Lambda equals plus or minus
I this is a linear
Center
okay so this fixed Point here at 0 0 is
locally if I zoom in really close it's
going to look like a center it's going
to have these little rotating circles
given by these kinds of linearized
Dynamics so I'm actually going to draw
that okay I'm going to draw that this
thing locally
has these little local local centers and
you have to be careful about what the
direction of the arrows points
um
if I start with a little test Vector 1 0
which is in the one zero position and I
multiply it I get something that is zero
negative one which I believe means it's
pointing down
so I think that these arrows are going
this way but you need to be careful you
need to be careful when you draw these
to make sure you get the direction of
the arrows right this is I think going
clockwise I put in a little test Vector
that was you know in the plus x 0 y
direction a little one zero Vector there
or a little Epsilon zero and when I
multiply it I get something that is 0
negative one so it's kind of pointing
down I'm pretty sure okay that's how I
do this one so that was my first fixed
Point
um let's see maybe my second fixed Point
um
maybe I will do this one in in blue why
not so my second
fixed Point uh is at one zero
and so again I evaluate my Jacobian this
Jacobian here but now every time I see
an X I plug in one okay so my Jacobian
dfdx
evaluated at at one zero
is now equal to zero one negative 1 plus
2 is plus one plus one zero
okay now this system is you can compute
the eigenvalues this is kind of like you
know you can pause here and compute the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors this is a
good homework problem I'm just going to
write them down that Lambda equals plus
or minus 1 which means that this is a
saddle point
and specifically that means that there
is an unstable and a stable direction of
this of this system but we need to know
what direction they're pointing what are
the stable and unstable directions what
are the eigenvectors of this Matrix
because that's going to tell me which
direction stable and unstable so I know
that this thing is going to have stable
and unstable directions but I need to
know what the eigenvectors are again I'm
going to save you a little bit of a
headache and just write them down that
C1 is equal to 1 1
that's the eigenvector corresponding to
um
the unstable Plus One Direction and C2
is equal to the one minus One Direction
that's the eigenvector corresponding to
the stable Direction so here now I can
show that this thing has stable and
unstable directions
that are kind of in this 45 degree angle
across where I believe this one
is stable is sorry is unstable and this
one
is stable
about the system this is all that we can
say about the system
um just by local linearization is we
found the fixed points we computed the
local derivative of the Dynamics we kind
of tailor expanded these Dynamics and
using a small approximation a small
neighborhood approximation came up with
these linear Dynamics so literally x dot
and V Dot equals this a matrix times x
and v in this little neighborhood and x
dot and V Dot equals this Matrix times x
and v in this little neighborhood and so
far that's all I can say
but because this is a mechanical system
and I can draw this picture I can gain a
little bit more intuition and I can I
can actually finish the global phase
portrait of this uh of this dynamical
system and the way we do that is by
imagining what if I was at this point
here and maybe maybe I'll I'll make sure
that we understand what these phase
portraits mean locally first and then
I'll show you how to complete the
picture
so imagine I'm at this fixed point
I'm a little particle or a little bead
that is near this fixed point so let's
say I start at this location here at the
positive x v equals zero so that means
I'm in a positive X location I'm right
here with zero velocity
what's going to happen I let my system
go and it's going to X is going to start
decreasing X is going to start
decreasing and X as X decreases my
velocity is going to pick up my velocity
is going to increase in the negative
Direction so my velocity is increasing
in the negative Direction
my velocity is going to Peak as it
passes through x equals zero so my
maximum negative velocity is at x equals
0. and then it's going to start going up
this hill my velocity is going to get
smaller and smaller and smaller X is
going to get more and more and more
negative that's exactly what happens
here
until at its peak x value my velocity is
zero and then it's going to turn around
and it's going to be kind of oscillating
in this
you know in in physical space that
causes corresponds to these oscillations
in Phase space these little circles
so you can convince yourself
um that you know this little oscillation
here of this particle is the same as the
thing going around that's very physical
and intuitive
same thing here
if I push my system a little bit in the
X direction or if I give it a little
positive velocity in the positive X
Direction it's going to roll off to this
infinity and similarly if I push it left
here it's going to roll off this way
and so this is how we're going to
complete these pictures we're going to
imagine what if I took this particle and
I pushed it the teeniest tiniest Epsilon
left of that fixed point or I give it
the tiniest tiniest velocity in this
direction what's going to happen is it's
going to roll down this hill and because
there's no friction it's going to roll
up the hill
to a point that's exactly at the same
height the same potential energy
and then it's going to turn around and
it's going to roll back
and it's going to over a very long time
slowly creep up this hill and eventually
come back to this the place where it
started this is for like an Epsilon
Epsilon infinitesimal nudge to the left
it's going to take almost forever to
move away but eventually it will it'll
come up here turn around and then roll
right back
and that corresponds to kind of starting
with a teeny tiny little perturbation of
the system either in the X direction or
in the v Direction
and so I can take this unstable
Direction
and essentially it will eventually
come back to the stable Direction the
stable direction is the one that you
know if I started out here I would
eventually come back uh and roll right
up to the tippy top of this hill very
very
uh gradually
and I didn't draw this perfectly this
point here should line up with this
vertical Point here this should be like
this should line up to a point that is
at the same height as that I can fix
this by just making my potential a
little steeper I can totally cheat and
just make this thing a little bit
steeper so that you know at this height
here
my potential goes through that point
problem solved
and so what this means is that if I
perturb my system a teeny tiny bit off
of this in just the right direction it
will move to the left and pick up a
negative velocity
and at this maximum velocity Point here
at the bottom of the hill it will then
start to lose velocity as it goes uphill
my velocity my velocity direction is
getting smaller it'll hit a potential
energy that was equal to its starting
energy at which point x can't go any
farther it can't go any farther up here
and now it's going to turn around and
its velocity is going to start to
increase in the positive direction while
X turns around and goes back up the hill
and over this will take an infinite
amount of time to take this this Loop
because it'll take you know if I start
with
0.0001 you know perturbation it'll take
a really long time for this thing to
eventually leave that neighborhood
um so around here and around here it'll
take almost forever to leave and to come
back this part will be fast
and so we've actually drawn
in linear structure this is like a
global structure it's not from the
linearization this is just from physics
from intuition
um similarly did I lose my blue pen
I lost my blue pen
similarly if I push this thing a teeny
bit in the right direction that's this
direction here this thing is just going
to go on to Infinity
and so these kind of correspond to
trajectories that are just kind of you
know if I start with any X out here and
zero velocity it's just going to roll on
to Infinity it's going to pick up
velocity and move to positive Infinity
um so that's this axis here or if I
start
um
I guess any point
at this location x with any positive
velocity I'm also going to go to
Infinity so I believe these will all
kind of go to Infinity
and down here if I start with
um
a particle here
the same the same location if I start
with the particle at this location but
now I have a negative velocity meaning
I'm kicking it in this direction what
it's going to do is it's going to make
one big loop
around it's going to if I kick it with a
big positive velocity it's going to make
one big loop it's going to overshoot
it's going to go farther
and then it's going to turn around and
go to negative Infinity that's what this
means it's going to overshoot turn
around and then go to negative Infinity
with a positive sorry positive Infinity
with a positive velocity I'm getting
confused this is positive Infinity
um once it crests this hill it goes to
positive Infinity with a positive
velocity
and this is the global phase portrait of
this system and you can see that these
you know presumably have to get kind of
stretched out and warped eventually into
this kind of cat's eye but this is what
the global dynamics of the system look
like okay so really powerful idea you
can take non-linear differential
equations you can find their fixed
points
you can linearize about those fixed
points to find out if they're you know
centers or spirals or saddles or
whatever and then you can draw at least
locally what the face portraits are and
sometimes if you're lucky you can reason
through what the global face portrait is
good
I'm going to show you is what if I added
some friction here what if I added some
damping some uh
you know maybe minus V here so now this
is minus V
what else is going to change this is a
minus V and now this Jacobian here this
is going to be a
minus one
minus one
in this case where I've added a little
bit of friction to all of this my saddle
is essentially it is going to have a
minus one here but it's still going to
have saddle type Behavior it's still
going to have saddle Dynamics but now my
Center is going to have like a minus one
down here and my Center is going to
become a stable
a stable spiral
sink
so my eigenvalues are now going to be
Lambda equals some little negative
number some negative number negative a
plus or minus I for this Center here and
so my saddle is going to stay a saddle
my Center is now going to become a
stable spiral okay so you can confirm
maybe you don't make this minus one V
maybe make it minus 0.1 V or 0.01 V and
then it'll be more obvious what's
happening
and I can draw that case here so
um
this was uh
no friction
and this case is going to be with
friction
with friction and so my saddle Dynamics
are still going to look like saddle
Dynamics they're still going to be
saddle but now my
fixed Point here instead of having
concentric circles things are going to
be spiraling in
to the origin like that
and so
um again this is all that I can say
locally is that this is what the
Dynamics looks like
I think those are my unstable and my
stable directions but again you can
reason through what's likely to happen I
wish I had a purple marker what's likely
to happen is that if I just nudge this a
tiny bit from this point a tiny bit from
this fixed Point what's going to happen
is that this is going to lose energy and
eventually connect onto that spiral and
spiral into the origin and so you can
kind of again reason through what the
Dynamics of this system will look like
for uh even more kind of global
Global Dynamics so that's I think kind
of a cool thing is that you can you know
add friction change your eigenvalues so
now they have a little stable uh damping
for this fixed Point here now this is
like if I have a ball rolling it's
eventually going to die out that's what
this is saying here
and now this orbit connects
to that spiral into that fixed point and
that's physically very intuitive if I
nudge this point a teeny bit to the left
it's going to roll but not quite as high
as it did before and then it's going to
roll not quite as high as before not
quite as high as before and it's
eventually going to die out in this well
so really cool things you can do from
some combination of linearization local
linearization and looking at eigenvalues
and eigenvectors and trying to draw
these phase portraits
all right thank you
thank you
[Music]